et avec nous pourrons parler en direct
par skype pierre chasserait délégué
général de 40 millions d'automobilistes
bonsoir alexis poulain éditorialistes rt
france et enfin jérôme rodriguez gilet
jaune bonsoir a tous les droits et merci
d'être avec nous on va voir ce graphique
1 pour bien voir l'évolution est l'état
des lieux du prix du carburant ces
dernières semaines en un mois vous le
voyez les prix à la pompe n'ont cessé
d'augmenter cette semaine donc on
atteint des records on le disait moyen
le prix moyen du gazole a grimpé de plus
de 3 centimes pierre chasserait on a
entendu ces français s'inquiétait la
situation devient tout de même alarmante
ils sont inquiets à juste titre les
français et ça fait quelques mois
maintenant quelques années l'association
40 millions d'automobilistes on tire la
sonnette d alarme on peut être très
clair je vais vous dire ce qui va se
passer soit l'état prend la mesure de ce
qui se passe sur les carburants qui est
la taxe visible de toutes les taxes en
france partout où il passait le long des
routes vous voyez ces panneaux qui vous
affiche les prix des carburants soit
l'état prend la mesure dont ça va sur
une mesure politique qui répond à cette
attente des français soit ils n'y vont
pas si l'état ne va pas on risque de se
retrouver avec un mouvement social il
sera extrêmement important parce que là
c'est une ségrégation par l'argent si
vous avez l'argent pour faire le plein
circulez si vous n'avez pas l'argent
pour faire le plein il fait le choix
entre vous chauffer ou rouler pour aller
au boulot avec les gamins à l'école donc
on va avoir un souci autres petits
points très importants j'entends déjà ça
et là ce petit bois de bruno le maire
qui nous dit oui mais pour chaque
centime de moins de taxes sur les
carburants
ces 500 millions de moi dans l'hérault
dans les caisses de l'état alors je
salue sa rhétorique et son esprit de
conviction puisqu'il a réussi à
convaincre les médias de cette cette
hérésie mais ce n'est pas une réalité la
situation actuelle ce n'est pas ça ce
sont des prix du baril qui s'envole et
des taxes il s'envole aussi je rappelle
que les prix du carburant sont composés
de deux taxes vous avez là telle icpe ça
c'est une part fixe ce fx et vous avez
la tva 20 100 du prix global plus le
prix du de l'essence au lit cher plus la
part de tva est forte donc au contraire
la belle aubaine pour l'état plus le
prix du baril et au à chaque centime de
plus ces 500 millions encore de plus
fonctionner sur le dos des
automobilistes jérôme andreas quand vous
entendez pierre chasse remercie
d'ailleurs pour votre clarté et votre
pédagogie nous dire soit ils prennent
les bonnes mesures on va en parler plus
en détails de ces mesures ou alors ça va
être à nouveau une grogne sociale
d'ampleur comme on l'avait vu avec votre
mouvement
votre réaction
parce que dans le reportage que vous
avez diffusé alors je remercie monsieur
chat si j'ai bien compris parce que j'ai
déjà souvent tendus sur les plateaux et
je sais qu'il est très clair et
j'apprécie son discours on s'est même
rencontré sur plusieurs plateaux
d'ailleurs par contre la dernière
version que vous avez fait passer qui
est la halle qui fait appel au gilet
jaune si quand même magnifique quoi vous
savez ces fumeurs buveurs de bière qui
un jour ont décidé de descendre dans la
rue parce qu'il ya un certain problème
non pas que au niveau de l'essence mais
au niveau de sa globalité de l'énergie
parce que là on parle des voitures mais
en ce moment on est en hiver ya des gens
qui ont besoin de se chauffer le fioul a
pris une claque monumentale encore plus
que le gasoil que la deuxième chose qui
ne fait rien dans votre reportage c'est
les courbes enfin de belles courbes qui
sont censés aujourd'hui intéressé les
français à défaut d'être qu'on découpe
du corps vide enfin des cours qui
aujourd'hui impacte directement le
quotidien de l'ensemble des français
quand je vais rencontrer monsieur sur le
plateau j'avais fait juste un rapide
calcul comme ça de base sur une voiture
pour une famille vivant en province avec
50 km 50 km de moyenne affaires par jour
on était sur un budget de plus de 750
euros à sortir en plus sur l'année et je
ne parle que de l'essence je poserai
juste une question parce que dans sa
globalité c'est l'ensemble de l'énergie
quand on voit que l'excédent budgétaire
engrangés avec les 57 % de hausse du
prix du gaz
ça a ramené 7 milliards dans les poches
de l'état français ont été au tri
redistribuer dit pour cent sous forme de
primes d'énergie que d'ailleurs j'ai
toujours pas entendu parler parce que
pour le coup personne dans la rue bien
médias en europe on a gagné sans valve
ni même les deux sens d'ailleurs mais
qu'est ce qu'on a fait des 6 milliards
300 millions qui restent qu'est ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui de ce pognon alors oui
je suis ville ajoute parce
qu'aujourd'hui la vraie question d'un
gilet jaune mais qu'est ce qu'on fait de
tout ce pognon parce que tout ce qui a
été budgété sur l'année 2021 a été pris
sur une base d'une année passée les prix
s'éclate dans tous les sens ça fait un
max de pognon qu'ils rentrent dans les
poches de l'état on va cet argent moi
personnellement j'ai un problème avec
les impôts j'ai essayé les avants au
téléphone nous devions j'ai passé une
heure 17 au téléphone j'ai eu personne
on fait quoi du pognon aujourd hui voilà
parce qu'à dix faut que les français
payent si moment il ya quelque chose qui
suit derrière je paye des taxes très
bien je suis servi publiquement quand
j'ai un soucis de ji ou avec l'espace
public ne sera pas il n'y a pas de souci
pour moi mais aujourd'hui on paye des
taxes déjà horriblement cher sur un prix
horriblement cher et tout ce pognon
engrangé on en voit même pas la couleur
pour ne serait ce qui est des passez moi
l'expression à sortir le plus de la
merde de l'ensemble des français parce
que la conçoit gilet jaune ou pas qu'on
soit noir ou blanc qu'on soit chrétien
ou pas ou politique ou pas le prix
d'essence vacciner ou pas le prix décent
sont le pays tous et on va le payer tous
très cher et on le paye déjà très cher
alexis poulain à la question justement
de savoir si emmanuel macron et donc
impuissants à cette flambée des prix du
carburant parce qu'évidemment c'est pas
la première on va d'abord regarder ces
réactions t g qui nous parviennent avant
de vous donner la parole un petit peu
peur car le yohan cabaye ça va vous
plaire jérôme andrieu à 80 % des taxes
dans le prix c'est la seule fois où ils
seraient surpuissant emmanuel macron
voilà je vois que ça vous fait sourire
tous les trois un autre internaute nous
il faut bien se dire qu'il ne
redescendra pas l'hébreu descendront pas
les prix pourquoi le ferait il personne
ne bouge on rappelle cette mesure
annoncée par jean castex en octobre
jérôme rodriguez nous l'a rappelé en
euros à tous les français qui gagnent
moins de 2000 euros net par mois c'est
vrai que ça concerne pas tout le monde
oui jérôme rudin test c'était passe à
200 euros pour ceux qui gagnent moins
deux mille euros lissée sur l'année d'où
le fait qu'on donne la prime au mois de
décembre pour ce qui concerne le gasoil
je parle de la prime énergie 200 euros
qui devait être redistribués à des
français qui déclarait moins de 10000
846 euros d'impôts par an j'ai fait une
manif gilet jaune je vous garantis que
j'ai fait demandé aux personnes qui
déclarait moins de onze mille euros
d'impôts par an je garantis que 90 % des
gens ont levé la main j'aurais dit m
manque de bol les 100 euros sous le zen
légales y en aura pour personne voilà
c'est idéal place alexis paulin ça me
revient à dire que voilà emmanuel macron
ce gouvernement en tout cas s'est montré
impuissant face à cette problématique de
flambée des prix du carburant
complètement et de toute façon c'est sur
de nombreux sujets que ce gouvernement
impuissant mais particulièrement sur le
pouvoir d'achat avec même une
déconnexion typique du gouvernement ma
chronique depuis des mois allant même
jusqu'à essayer de faire la promotion du
bilan d' emmanuel macron sur le pouvoir
d'achat des français alors que tous les
français seront des comptes qu'ils
avaient perdu en pouvoir d'achat mais
grâce à des arguties et des calculs
exceptionnel les députés de la
république en marche arrivait à défendre
ce bilan dans un an vous avez gagné
alors oui les français les plus riches
effectivement on peut être un peu gagné
la majorité des français par la hausse
du prix de logement la hausse de
l'énergie la hausse de la vie
quotidienne des produits de la vie de
tous les jours ont perdu en pouvoir
d'achat parce que les salaires n'ont pas
suivi comme d'habitude donc on voit bien
que de toute façon emmanuel macron
organise encore une fois son incapacité
son irresponsabilité à trois mois de
l'élection présidentielle il a pourtant
là une autoroute 1 pour gagner des
points dans les sondages s'il arrivait à
dire ok on va arrêter avec les chèques
s'emballe par 600 euros par là pour
colmater les brèches et on va faire une
politique de moyen à long terme
énergétique parce que non seulement
l'essence coûte cher mais on en parlait
ça va être toute l'énergie qui va coûter
cher le fuel évidemment mais l'énergie
nucléaire également edf obligés de
brader son énergie pour faire vivre une
fausse concurrence organisé par
bruxelles on a su enfin là vraiment
un des murs qui risque d'être le plus
catastrophique c'est ce coût de
l'énergie dans les années qui viennent
parce que sur l'essence c'est environ 15
points 5 milliards de litres qui sont
consommées chaque jour par par la
planète et ça n'arrête pas c'est dire
qu'on n'est pas dans une économie où on
va devenir un peu plus modérée avec la
chine qui est de plus en plus gourmande
en énergie avec l'inde également des
pays qui ont besoin d'énergie et nous
aussi donc on est dans un une équation
qui est
fatalement ne peut pas être résolu si ce
n'est par la hausse du prix et rendre
ces matières premières qui étaient
abordables les rendre inabordable en
faire un produit de luxe or désolé sans
voiture bas beaucoup de français ne
pourront pas aller travailler ne
pourront pas vivre tout simplement vont
mourir de faim chez eux les matières
premières vont pas pouvoir être
acheminée et derrière c'est toute la
logique de l'inflation qui se met en
place également donc non seulement ce
coût à la pompe il est hors de prix mais
l'inflation elle est aussi emmené par ce
prix de l'énergie chère et aucun enfin
et je vois encore une fois demain de
macron sera au parlement de strasbourg
ou de bruxelles au parlement européen
pour faire le beau expliquer quelle sera
sa présidence de l'union européenne
pendant quelques mois est ce que
l'europe est capable de faire une
politique énergétique la réponse est non
alors par contre pour évidemment avoir
quelques viseo stratégique sur north
stream et et empêcher ça et là des
achats d'électricité ou de gaz à bon
prix il ya plus personne faire des
champions d'électricité ou de l'énergie
impossible également d'ailleurs ces
mails macron qui a été à la manoeuvre
pour la vente d'alstom aux américains
donc on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas de
réflexion par rapport à l'énergie en
tant que moyen de souveraineté et entend
aussi que force de devis pour la plupart
des français parce que une énergie moins
chère c'est aussi une vie meilleure
pierre chasseresse vais vous montrer ce
graphic arts en continu tous les prix
aujourd'hui le prix du baril qui a
atteint un niveau historique le brent et
le west texas intermediate
intermediate pardon n'ont jamais été
aussi haut depuis sept ans avec des
montants fixés aujourd'hui entre 87 et
et 85 dollars ça veut dire quoi
concrètement vous avez commencé à nous
donner une réponse mais tout de même
et la question que se posent beaucoup de
monde et c'est ce qu'on essaye de nous
faire croire peut-être le gouvernement
qu'il une vraie marge de manoeuvre quand
vous voyez aussi qu'il y a des effets
climatiques géopolitique nominés nominés
par jérôme brudy reste je suis obligé de
poser la question pour qu'on nous donne
l'explication voilà jérôme jaffré
je ne connais pas celui-là non bien
choisir et josé moi c'est jérôme dumas
qui m'a troublé voilà cherchait
précisément
on préfère alors passer l'humour message
adressé au conseil positif en l'état
actuel
si les perspectives de reprise
économique soit l'international en
sortie pour le virus c'est ce qu'on
souhaite tous un branchement n'en peut
plus donc il va y avoir une utilisation
en scène je vous rappelle qu'en ce
moment la france est en télétravail ou
une partie de la population dans cette
population va rob andrew la route elle
doit y avoir une demande croissante en
carburants qu'il va faire mécaniquement
encore monter les prix du carburant là
actuellement pendante où les supari à
plus de 2 euros le litre et en france
aux alentours de 20 euros 69 70 selon
les carburants je pense qu'il faut être
très clair il faut parler à la france
des provinces et expliqué que si le
gouvernement ne sait rien on aura deux
euros le litre partout et bien plus dans
les grandes villes donc c'est
insupportable on va avoir ce que c'est
quoi la conséquence c'est la
désertification des zones rurales parce
que lorsque vous êtes un et bien vous
pouvez pu assumer de voiture pour partir
au travail donc vous déménagez c'est
c'est tout notre territoire et tout ce
qui fait la spécificité la richesse de
notre territoire
ces campagnes ces villes qui va être mis
en balance demain c'est parce que la
boîte son travail c'est rigolo mais il
n'ya pas que ça et aussi en est ces
gamins à l'école les emmenait à des
activités sportives c'est aussi partir
en week-end partiront famille et
retrouver les amis du temps social il
faut qu'on en parle du temps social on
en a besoin aussi et tout ça c'est le
vélo cher pierre chasserait pour partir
je suis pas je peux lui dire j'ai aussi
pas d'un vélo moi je veux bien mais je
veux l'avoir reçue avant donc c'est j'ai
vu partir en campagne présidentielle je
n'ai pas vu monter sur un vélo donc
soyons réalistes un petit peu dorénavant
ce qu'il faut se reprendre un peu de
pragmatisme
il n'y a pas cinquante solutions il y en
a qu'une donc le message qu'on va
envoyer au président de la république
idée simple il ya soit il le fait soit
il ne sait pas s de l'avis des mois qui
a chassé il ya des candidats en tout cas
qui ont leurs propositions on va aller
les voir s'afficher un jean luc
mélenchon à bloquer les prix tout
simplement hidalgo marine le pen baisser
la tva à 5.5 yannick jadot vous dévoyez
s'afficher un chèque énergie je résume
volontairement valérie pécresse soyons
un forfait kilométrique
jérôme rodriguez il ya des compositions
qui vous séduisent plus que d'autres
parmi ces candidats sans faire forcément
la pub de l'un d'entre eux mais en tout
cas sur cette question même de du
carburant et de l'énergie
mais mais tous les gens venaient me
présenter son qui aujourd'hui face à des
mecs qui prennent une navette pour aller
dans l'espace aujourd'hui ils ont dix
fois plus de puissance en pognon que ces
gens là
aujourd'hui le problème de l'essence
c'est le côté vicieux de l'augmentation
des prix parce que une journée on va
mais tente qu'ils centimes par 6 à
lhassa glisse de centimes par là un ou
deux centimes par ici et puis là on
arrive à 1,062 moi je vais vous dire
c'est du concret j'ai perdu le droit de
conduire mais j'ai été maître de
l'essence avait longtemps que j'avais
pas été mettre de l'essence j'ai saigné
du nez c'est ça le concret c'est ça j'ai
mis un billet de 50 euros j'étais dans
le conflit je veux 50 euros j'ai pas eu
30 litres en gasoil
50 euros je n'ai pas eu 30 litres c'est
ça qui percute dans la tête des français
c'est parce que tous les jours on leur
met un centime de plus ils ne le sont
pas passés il ya un moment donné où il
ya rupture et c'est là où c'est trop
tard tous ces gens là les maquereaux et
toute autre personne aujourd'hui n'ont
aucune puissance face à des sociétés qui
ont plus on leur favoriser on leur
déroule le tapis rouge à parce que je
pense pas que le boulanger a le même
ordre d'imposition que peut avoir totale
parce que je vous garantis que la
sécurité sociale gré beaucoup mieux mais
vraiment beaucoup mieux c'est que ad ou
de les contraindre on va contraindre les
français ne puissent se déplacer à des
chenaux contraintes des sociétés qui
font des milliards et des milliards à ne
même pas remboursé l'ensemble de la
pollution qui crie défavorise l'ensemble
des français c'est quand même
merveilleux ce pays on vit dans un pays
magique et c'est là où son comptable
concret parce qu on aura beau dire pour
sentir pourcentage pourcentage mais là
c'est du pognon je le répète voulez-vous
répondre à gérer gaston géo à la nano
s'entend bien que les grands pétroliers
gagne de l'argent n'était pas de
problème sauf que sur un tarif des
carburants son ensemble 100 de la somme
mais à 65 à 70% qui part dans les
caisses de l'état donc les seuls qui se
passe et s'en remet la pression pierre
simon 60% de blé pour pouvoir par
exemple quand ya une épidémie de
convives être superbement bien soigné à
l'hôpital je les lâche les 60% on a
lâché 60% depuis qu'ils sont nés sur du
gasoil on se retrouve avec une épidémie
la gueule dans l'eau à ne pas pouvoir
être soigné dans de bonnes conditions
pays la france champion du monde de la
santé il ya un paradoxe il ya quelque
chose qui passe pas il ya quelque chose
que les français aujourd'hui ne se pose
pas c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait déjà de
cet argent parce qu'on nous le prends
auquel on peut comprendre les mécanismes
on peut les entendre mais qu'est ce
qu'on fait ce pognon ou est-ce qui va
que cet argent pourquoi on n'a pas
remboursé la dette monde de france avec
tout cet argent qu'on engrange avec nos
taxes avec nos taxes on appelle ça un
pot solidaire aujourd'hui à des gens qui
dorment dans la rue
passé 65 cents fois voyez ce que c'est
moi je voudrais juste qu'à un moment
donné qu'on essaie d'inverser le
problème je vais je vais vous en donner
juste un dernier exemple on a en a violé
parce qu'on allait nous prendre 135
euros sur le compteur linky
et on nous a donné comme argument de la
part d'edf que mais vous rendez compte
vous n'aurez plus de contrôleurs qui
passe chez vous mais moi je m'en fous
qu'il passe à la maison je paye 135
euros il a un salaire il peut nourrir sa
famille les joueurs et les gens ne
réfléchissent plus on va m'enlever 135
euros bois ça va on est en france les
plus pauvres vont pas on va pas leur
enlever mais les plus riches mais tu va
financer un mec tu vas tu vas juste
enlever le boulot d'un mec parce que tu
es content qu'ils viennent pas chez toi
t'emmerder mais moi je suis content
qu'ils nourrissent ma famille sa famille
les 135 euros il faudrait juste que les
gens remettent les choses alors bonne
place quoi si à un moment donné on paye
on mérite de recevoir sochaux à défaut
de recevoir et je suis désolé j'ai un
problème de prothèses en ce moment mais
moi les sens ça m'a fait perdre un oeil
quoi à l'excellence littéral du terme
cette colère qu'on entend effectivement
ce réalisme face à la pompe à essence à
ce que c'est quand même quelque chose
qui peut jouer des gros tours à emmanuel
macron qui il faut bien le dire pour
l'instant ce maintien quand même assez
haut dans les sondages à trois mois de
la présidentielle
mais c'est ça qui est incompréhensible
en fait le la place des modèles macron
dans les sondages pose question son
bilan est difficilement défendable j'en
parlais sur le pouvoir d'achat mais sur
le reste enfin on n'a rien vu la gestion
sanitaire n'en parlons pas c'est un
autre débat mais à part enfermer les
français elle est traitée de vouloir les
emmerder on n'a pas vu grand chose et
est derrière est évidemment là avec ses
7 ce prix de l'essence qui est plus haut
que lors du mouvement de gilet jaune est
toujours l'idée est bien sûr de faire
porter le pli à la masse de français
plutôt qu'aux pollueur payeur à ceux qui
pourraient payer le prix on voit bien
qu'il ya un problème or les français
n'ont plus la force d'aller dans la rue
on a l'impression ne serait ce que pour
défendre leurs libertés fondamentales
contre le pass sanitaire déjà il ya très
peu de monde et puis voilà jérôme est
l'exemple de la violence d'état qui
s'est décrit s'est déversée sur les
manifestants gilet jaune je crois que
c'était une violence qui a été fait à
dessein pour déterrer pour faire peur
pour empêcher finalement qu'il ya
d'autres mouvements de masse populaire
contre un gouvernement qui gouverne
contre son pays tout simplement et je
crois que là aujourd'hui on a toutes les
clés pour que à nouveau y ait un
mouvement insurrectionnel quasiment que
ce soit la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
l'inflation la façon dont cet exécutif
nous traitent en piétinant les libertés
et qu'est ce qu'on voit quelques faible
mobilisation des syndicats qui de temps
en temps pour une manifestation contre
un ministre qui était à ibiza la veille
de la rentrée bon visiblement ça ne
choque plus les profs et tout et que
tout est à l'envi c'est à dire que une
fatigue quand une résignation aussi du
fait de la violence de la force
finalement de bulldozer demel mac
d'exploser toutes les revendications
sociales de s'essuyer les pieds sur le
finalement le paillasson de ses
revendications sociales et d'avancer
quoi qu'il en coûte le quoi qu'il en
coûte c'est quoi c'est à dire écoutez
rester tranquille on va vous financer
jusqu'à ce que vous fassiez faillite
quand on va débrancher le quoi qu'il en
coûte après les présidentielles sans
doute après que le maquereau se soient
déclarés candidats là on aura les
faillites ce sera donc très très
longtemps ce sera trop tard pour pleurer
et tout est comme ça c'est ce que disait
jérôme c'est à dire que on ne se rend
pas compte de ces petites causes de
cette perte de liberté toutouba tous
mentent ou va crescendo mais
suffisamment lentement en tant que
personne ne se rendre compte de
l'ampleur finalement du danger et de la
nécessité d'une mobilisation nationale
et et voilà et pourtant quelques
lanceurs d'alertés sont là pour en
parler mais malheureusement on voit bien
que derrière il ya une tranquillité qui
qui moi me pose question merci en tout
cas à tous les trois pierres chasserait
jérôme rodriguez alexis poplin d'avoir
été avec nous pour pour débattre de
cette flambée des prix du carburant
merci à vous